tim is in hartford connecticut hi tim
welcome to the ramsay show hey how you
doing
better than i deserve how can i help
good i first want to say thank you i
came across
you know some of your videos and things
online have been extremely helpful and
very informative so thank you for all
that that you do
thank you um question i'm calling that's
i'm a physician
i have mid 30's marinated two kids uh my
wife and i between both of us
uh from undergraduate and medical school
at about a little over a hundred
000 combined runs and uh
right now currently you saved up a nice
emergency fund savings
you actually have enough to pay off all
of that essentially
are you there sounds like we just lost
him
oh oh wait a minute and maybe now
are you there tim oh let me pick back up
all right i'll try again
i think they're messing with you in the
booth there brother all right hey tim
are you there
yeah yeah can you hear me yeah that was
all kelly's fault we'll just blame her
but um anyway the uh uh sorry about that
so you have a hundred thousand dollars
in student loan debt and you have a
hundred thousand dollars in the
well bank give or take them you know i'm
a physician in practice in the 30s
married with two kids
what's your household income uh we're
making
program with bonuses and everything just
short of about 400. good for you
and we've got um we've got about 107 and
loans between us
i've got 15 savings and about 130
and checking that it's sort of an
earmark to pay off the loans and
obviously things are on those lines
um you know the cars are paid off for a
few years very reasonable
so your question is what tim uh question
specifically is
with all the pending legislation and
discussion about loan forgiveness out
there
and when my wife and i are trying to
divide on this to get a second opinion
essentially just to pay this all off we
ride this out keep making payments and
see what's potentially going to come
over the next
year or several years with regard to
loan forgiveness
well um looking at that through three or
four different lenses
i would write a check today and pay off
your student loans but let me give you
the lenses that i'm looking at it
through
and tell you how i came to that
conclusion um
number one uh
you borrowed the money you owe the money
waiting on me to pay off your student
loans as a taxpayer pisses me off
number two um
[Music]
the if they do pass this legislation
there
well there's nothing legislation there's
been a lot of discussion
i have never seen anyone
except uh the very far edge
fringe of the left suggesting any more
than fifty thousand dollars worth of
forgiveness
and a lot of the forgiveness proposals
that have been floated
uh are limited for high income earners
so on a practical basis if it did come
through it's probably not going to pay
off all of your loans
and if it did come through um
you're you are a real candidate for it
being limited it seems to be aimed at
there's a discussion of up to fifty
thousand there's a discussion at ten
thousand
uh and and a lot of the discussions were
income
limited uh meaning that if you were
making the kind of money you're making
you wouldn't qualify
because you're an evil rich person and
you must be punished in socialism so
um the um uh the third thing is
just as a matter of philosophical
even theologically the way i live my
life i just have never met
anyone who uh had a wonderful life
waiting on the government to fix it
right and so i just i just resist the
whole idea of
those idiots are coming to the rescue
because i'm
old and i've never seen them do it
right all they've ever done is take all
they've ever done is take from me
they've never given me anything
now they talk a lot and there's a lot of
you know
if if words were now if words were if
you could monetize their words we'd had
some money but
but they just talk and so real people do
what you do you went and got a medical
degree you have a wonderful medical
practice just go be prosperous and
don't wait on them to be your
your supply so to speak john you've got
a degree in higher ed
uh what are you thinking in this it goes
it to me it's less about the government
it's a it goes back to your original
point it's a personal integrity thing
for me
which is right i i
signed my name on a piece of paper i
looked some in the eye and said hey if
you'll help me get through school i
promise i'll pay you back
and man you're making four hundred
thousand dollars i'd write this check
today and
high five my family and take my family
out for a debt-free dinner tomorrow
night
right well combined between my wife but
i understand your point that's what
we've kind of been
wrestling with is that we're obviously
you know doing well we've been able to
save and lived very
uh you know moderately to you know save
what we've done right well you're gonna
you know you're gonna be worth
you're gonna have an incredible net
worth and uh and i don't
um want you to have anything but that um
you know i i really don't um people are
like well
medical doctors make too much uh listen
i don't want
people that aren't good at their medical
practice working on me
they keep you alive you know i don't
want them practicing on me you know so
uh practice on somebody else but yeah i
mean i
i like my doctor being expensive
it's it's preferable to me i uh i'm
really happy when the dentist drives a
really nice car that
probability he's not gonna hurt me and
i'm pretty much a [ __ ] so
um you know i like that i i want to have
i want to
do business with successful people when
they're successful
is showing up in their wallet so i'm
proud for you tim that you're making all
this money
i i just it's a mindset for me that's
just making its way
from folks who are making 30 grand a
year that have 100 000
student loan debt all the way up to
making more than a quarter of a million
dollars
thinking oh man it's become a game now
how do i how do i
not pay it back right and i just man you
got the money in your account pay the
thing back it's the right thing to do
yep